kirst armor attacking the Prime Minister
if first he seemed to go quite quite
heavily on the Casey report yesterday he
certainly did I think Mr sunak has got
through pmq's pretty unscathed today no
difficult questions on uh Europe from
back benches or of course we've got this
uh debate and vote on the staunt breaks
that could all change as you say labor
focused on crime that party and that
leader realized it's something that
traditionally some would argue they've
been weak on and if they are to show
they are prepared ready for governing
they need to sort of toughen up at their
pitch to voters that's why a keystone
was very critical of the conservatives
hands-off attitude to policing talked
about their negligence over the last 13
years the Prime Minister uh rebuffing
that in particular talking about the
dysfunctional relationship Louise Casey
said that there is between the mayor of
London Sadiq Khan labor mayor of course
and with the Metropolitan Police now
even though crime was because this
wasn't really about partygate even
though there was one sort of brief nod
to that and a couple of the exchanges
the only criminal investigation he's
ever been involved in is the one that
found him guilty of breaking the law
Mr Speaker let me just address that the
issue The Honorable gentleman raised
because I said at the time I respected
the decision the police preached and I
offered an unreserved apology but for
the avoidance of downward speaker at the
moment that happened there was a full
investigation by a very senior civil
servant
things of which
confirmed that I had no
its knowledge about what have been
[Applause]
early for a meeting but he doesn't need
he doesn't need me to tell him that he's
probably spoken to the report's author
much more frequently than I have
the Prime Minister Jane there referring
to sue gray who a few weeks ago Scotty's
revealed has been recruited by
kierstanba to be his new Chief of Staff
certainly the strategy from
um the labor party seems to Echo sort of
new Labor's pitch of course Tony Blair
back in 93 so 30 years ago talked about
being tough on crime tough on the causes
of a crime when he was Shadow Home
Secretary not uh when he was leading the
opposition today Rishi sunak seemed to
Echo and repurpose that saying that
labor a soft on crime and uh stopped on
criminals I'm sure this may be a
Battleground in the general election but
as I say which is soon I think will be
pleased that he's got through pmqs the
Big Challenge now is to persuade enough
a conservative MPS to back him so that
Rebellion isn't so big that he doesn't
have a conservative uh loses the
conceptual majority on the assortment
break that vote this afternoon we know
it will pass we know Parliament will
back it but will a majority of
conservatives back